sie sind wieder an der macht 20 jahre
nach ihrer vertreibung beherrschen die
taliban afghanistan ein regime das von
keinem staat anerkannt wird ein land das
keine internationalen finanzhilfen mehr
erhält ich frage mich wie hat sich die
lebensrealität von 40 millionen afghanen
verändert
wer sind die gewinner
wer die verlierer
ich treffe die die an westliche werte
geglaubt haben und nun angst um ihr
leben haben
immer mehr kinder leiden an
unterernährung drohen an hunger zu
sterben in den krankenhäusern fehlt es
an medikamenten
ärzte bitten um unsere hilfe
zählen aus einem land dem der kollaps
droht
kabul früh morgens um 7 drei monate ist
es her dass die taliban die macht
übernommen haben
für die mädchen hier hat sich seit der
machtübernahme der taliban alles
verändert nur noch bis zur sechsten
klasse dürfen sie in der sache oder
schule lernen dann ist schluss von den
einst 8000 schülerinnen sind nur noch
2000 geblieben der früher überfüllte
pausenhof wirkt jetzt fast leer
die sechste klasse schreibt gerade eine
mathearbeit
die elfjährige julia und ihre freundin
mara sind die klassenbesten sagt hommage
an schott die lehrerin welche fragen
müssen sie beantworten frage ich ruft ag
soll die frage ist definiere die
prozentzahl mit einem beispiel die
prozentzahl ist die zahl die von 100
abgeleitet wird
isra will ärztin werden ich möchte
wissen warum was sie sich unter diesem
beruf vorstellt
ich will patienten behandeln
der grund für das land arbeiten
finden sie es gut dass mädchen und
jungen getrennt voneinander lernen
müssen
nein wir sind nicht glücklich
wir möchten zusammen mit jungen lernen
wie brüder und schwestern
[Musik]
vielleicht werden news rahma war und
ihre klassenkameradinnen nach den ferien
nicht mehr in die schule zurückkehren
und alle ihre träume platzen
einige dieser kinder wollen eines tages
parlamentsmitglieder werden aber so wie
die dinge laufen scheint das unmöglich
sie sind kinder sie verstehen noch nicht
in ernst dieser laden und versuchen ihr
bestes um ärzte oder ingenieure zu
werden
ich frage mich ob sie keine angst hat so
offen die taliban zu kritisieren
haben keine angst vor den taliban
wir fürchten nichts außer gott zu
glauben an gott aber wir auch wenn sie
uns unterdrücken werden sie dafür eines
tages bezahlen müssen
ich bin beeindruckt von ihrem mut
hommage am start möchte gerne in kontakt
bleiben wir tauschen unsere
telefonnummern aus dass die europäer sie
nicht vergessen ist den lehrerinnen
wichtig die afghanischen frauen haben in
den letzten 20 jahren viel gewonnen der
zugang zu bildung war dabei das
wichtigste doch jetzt drohen sie alles
wieder zu verlieren
das frauenministerium haben die taliban
geschlossen stattdessen ist jetzt ein
ministerium für tugenden und laster
entstanden wir sind zu besuch in der
neuen behörde sprecher aktiv moratti hat
uns zum tee eingeladen
statt der verfassung gilt jetzt der
koran eine übersetzung in paschtu liegt
auf dem schreibtisch wir haben gehört
die taliban haben sich im vergleich zu
den neunziger jahren verändert stimmt
das
die taliban haben sich nicht verändert
20 jahre lang wurde in diesem land
falsche propaganda über uns verbreitet
wir haben für frieden und sicherheit
dieses landes gekämpft ein heiliger
krieg wir sind keine terroristen
also werden wir keine bestrafungen mehr
sehen steinigungen wie wir sie in den
90er jahren erlebt haben
nein
so wird es nicht kommen
niemand wird im namen des
jugendministeriums erniedrigt
wir werden keinen menschen entehren oder
beleidigen
das verbietet der koran
wie der westen sie wahrnimmt ist in
taliban wichtig ihre kämpfer sorgen für
ordnung und sicherheit sagen sie für
mich verbreiten sie eine atmosphäre der
angst die überall in der stadt spürbar
ist
menschen die für ein modernes leben
eingetreten sind trauen sich oft nicht
mehr auf die straße vor allem die frauen
doch kaputt war schon immer anders als
der rest des landes eine metropole
moderner und weltoffener wie ist die
situation auf dem land
wir verlassen kabul und fahren in die
provinz wardak
es ist das erste mal dass ich diese
strecke fahre noch vor wenigen monaten
war die landstraße in den süden des
landes kriegsgebiet
immer wieder sehen wir spuren von
sprengstoffanschlägen
riesige krater die explosionen von
autobomben im asphalt hinterlassen haben
diesmal reisen wir mit erlaubnis der
taliban die uns auch begleiten
sofort fällt mir die extreme dürre auf
felder die vertrocknen die menschen hier
können von der landwirtschaft schon
lange nicht mehr leben viele der
familien leiden hunger
obwohl es nur 50 kilometer sind brauchen
wir mehr als zwei stunden bis wir im
dorf katsch kalla ankommen vom
fortschritt der letzten 20 jahre ist
hier nichts zu sehen wir werden
misstrauisch beäugt ein ausländisches
fernsehteam sehen sie hier zum ersten
mal
das schiff hat uns eingeladen in sein
haus 13 menschen leben hier zusammen sei
jetzt kinder eltern und ein bruder mit
behinderung eine afghanische großfamilie
die taliban haben uns geholfen eine
familie zu finden die bereit ist mit uns
vor der kamera zu sprechen die
machthaber möchten uns zeigen wie
schlecht es den menschen geht der westen
soll seine finanzhilfen wieder freigeben
das ist das ziel
das interview führen wir alleine mit der
familie unsere begleiter bitten wir
draußen zu warten
sattledt uns in sein haus ein er ist
sehr offen aber das will seine frau
sehen möchte er nicht es würde seine
ehre verletzt
seine mutter darf dabei sein
später kommt die älteste tochter dazu
streng verhüllt
früher konnten wir als tagelöhner für
einen der betriebe hier arbeiten und
jetzt ist das nicht mehr möglich ich
weiß nicht welches problem ich zuerst
lösen soll die miete bezahlen oder essen
die probleme sind so groß manchmal denke
ich ich bringe mich um
die ganze verzweiflung ist spürbar einen
ausweg aus der situation sehen sie nicht
die großmutter sieht die taliban
kritisch vor allem wenn es um ihre
enkelinnen geht wenn es für diese
mädchen einen platz zum studieren gibt
warum müssen sie aufhören wir wollen
dass sie studieren und etwas lernen das
ist gut und wichtig für die zukunft
ein paar kilometer entfernt am rande der
landstraße gibt es noch ein paar läden
der familienvater nimmt uns und seine
kinder mit zum einkauf es sind kaum
frauen zu sehen und überall taliban
kämpfer die ihre macht offen zur schau
stellen
sayed kauft t&t mit zucker und brot
davon ernähren sie sich fast
ausschließlich und die händler sehen sie
sich als profiteure des islamischen
emirats
die situation ist friedlich wir haben
afghanistan noch nie so friedlich
gesehen wie jetzt das einzige problem
sind die steigenden preise
ich frage mich trauen die menschen hier
den taliban zu eine funktionierende
wirtschaft aufzubauen
tolle woche da die taliban sind nicht
schuld an den problemen des landes die
probleme haben mit den ausländern zu tun
seitdem sie die internationale hilfe
gestrichen haben geht es uns schlecht
sie haben afghanistan sanktioniert
dass die ausländer schuld sein an der
wirtschaftlichen krise hören wir immer
wieder von den taliban der
sicherheitschef der provinz hat uns die
erlaubnis erteilt seine kämpfer zu
drehen
auch sie so erfahren wir später bekommen
keinen lohn mehr der staat ist
zahlungsunfähig seitdem die usa die
währungsreserven eingefroren haben für
die taliban geht es jetzt darum ihr
regime zu sichern
wir werden die errungenschaften aller
muslime verteidigen genau wie ihre
sicherheit wir werden mehr denn je für
sie arbeiten die leute die angst haben
oder vom krieg getroffen wurden müssen
in frieden leben sie müssen sich sicher
fühlen habt ihr das verstanden ihr
solltet euch genau merken dass ich
gesagt habe gott sei mit euch
bevor wir ins gebäude gelassen werden
müssen wir erneut an sicherheitsleuten
vorbei
dass der polizeichef mir beim interview
mit zwei bewaffneten kämpfern gegenüber
sitzt erstaunt mich
ich sehe sie haben zwei wächter mit
waffen warum
es gibt keine probleme mit der
sicherheit
trotzdem greifen wir die mudschahidin
sicherheitsmaßnahme
wir müssen die lage in unserem land
kontrollieren
was ist die bedrohung wer ist der feind
die leute die den krieg verloren haben
wie derwesten es ist ganz klar dass sie
den krieg an die taliban verloren haben
und die die die afghanen spalten wollen
die gegen fortschritt sind und gegen das
islamische system unsere feinde sind
auch neu entstandene gruppierungen wie
der islamische staat
wie brutal sie gegen ihre gegner
vorgehen haben die taliban seit ihrer
machtübernahme immer wieder gezeigt
in kabul bin ich mit einer sportlerin
verabredet die um ihr leben fürchtet wie
viele meiner kolleginnen erhalte ich
immer wieder nachrichten von
verzweifelten menschen die sich
versteckt halten und das land verlassen
wollen
an einem geheimen ort treffe ich mich
mit froh sein hardy der kapitänin des
afghanischen volleyball frauen teams
sie zeigt mir ein video das sie selbst
gemacht hat
es zeigt wie sie alles verbrennt was an
ihre zeit als volleyball spielerin
erinnert
trikots sportschuhe urkunden aus angst
vor den taliban habe sie alles
vernichtet
als die taliban an die macht kamen haben
sie eines unserer weiblichen
teammitglieder geköpft bilder davon sind
überall in den sozialen medien geteilt
worden wir können nicht beweisen dass es
die taliban waren denn jemand der ein
solches verbrechen begeht wird nicht
seinen namen nennen aber die familie hat
bestätigt dass ist die taliban waren
als leistungssportlerin hat froh sein
ihren lebensinhalt ihre leidenschaft
verloren sie hält sich versteckt muss
immer fürchten entdeckt zu werden ein
leben in angst war sie hatte jedoch
dadurch schon den coupons weiblichen
sportlerinnen geht es mental nicht gut
ich kann nicht einmal mehr klar denken
wir sind seit drei monaten in unserem
haus gefangen
videos zeigen froh sein mit ihrem team
ein spiel gegen bangladesch indem sie
mit der nummer zwei auftritt jetzt hofft
sie mit ihrer mannschaft afghanistan
verlassen zu können
wir haben überall wo man es sich nur
vorstellen kann um hilfe gebeten auch
die internationale volleyball
organisation habe ich um hilfe gebeten
bisher habe ich keine antwort erhalten
froh sein möchte dass wir sie zeigen
ihre geschichte erzählen ihre einzige
chance so sagt sie sei internationale
unterstützung hunderte afghanische
sportlerinnen haben bereits das land
verlassen
doch für die mehrheit der afghanen ist
es nicht die sorge um die freiheit die
sie verzweifeln lässt
sondern die angst ums überleben in den
straßen von kabul versuchen immer mehr
menschen auch kinder irgendwie ein paar
afghani zu ergattern
jeden tag verteilt die welthungerhilfe
in kabul im mehl und öl
nothilfe für eine 4 millionen statt
der staat erhält fast keine
internationalen finanzhilfen mehr sehr
viele hilfsprojekte sind gestoppt
der westen will die taliban nicht
unterstützen oder anerkennen und
riskiert gleichzeitig dass die
bevölkerung ins elend abstürzt
mafia mohammadi zeigt mir wie die
verteilung organisiert wird
ich möchte wissen wie sie entscheiden
welche familien lebensmittel erhalten
wir finden sie weil wir von tür zu tür
gehen wir sehen ihre häuser die
situation ist schlimm
es gibt viele familien die haben oft
über fünf tagen nichts zu essen und
müssen hungern
95 prozent der familien haben nichts zu
essen
23 millionen menschen drohen zu
verhungern
eine humanitäre katastrophe vor der auch
die vereinten nationen warnen und es
sind besonders die kinder auf die sich
die lage dramatisch auswirkt erzählt
marcia mohammadi
ich habe gehört dass viele afghanen ihre
kinder verkaufen vor allem mädchen um
geld zu bekommen um ihr leben fortsetzen
zu können das ist ein fakt
deshalb geben wir jeden tag lebensmittel
aus um zu verhindern dass familien ihre
kinder verkaufen
wir fahren raus aus kabul an den
stadtrand dort wird das mehl produziert
das die welthungerhilfe verteilt
es herrscht weitgehend stillstand
85 prozent der fabriken haben die
produktion eingestellt viele unternehmer
haben das land verlassen
die mühle ist eine der wenigen betriebe
die noch laufen der einzige auftraggeber
ist die welthungerhilfe
vor sieben jahren hat verwandte aus
schaan das unternehmen gekauft er will
weiter produzieren doch steht er vor
großen problemen weil die landwirtschaft
brach liegt muss er 90 prozent des
weizens aus kasachstan importieren doch
das unternehmen braucht dringend devisen
um die importe zu bezahlen sonst müssen
sie schließen
der unternehmer ist froh dass die alte
regierung abgetreten ist
er ist kein unterstützer der taliban
aber dass die korruption abgenommen hat
sei ein vorteil für unternehmer
in der alten regierung waren alle
korrupt
nicht nur einer
von dem ganzen geld das die usa hierher
gebracht haben ich würde sagen 50
prozent sind der korruption zum opfer
gefallen
20 jahre westliche entwicklungshilfe in
milliarden-höhe und trotzdem zählte
afghanistan bereits vor der
machtübernahme der taliban zu den
ärmsten ländern der welt vor allem für
kinder hat sich die lage nun dramatisch
verschlechtert
auf der straße haben wir die achtjährige
fatimah kennengelernt ihre eltern haben
uns erlaubt dass wir ihre tochter einen
tag lang begleiten
fatima muss als schuhputzer in geld
verdienen
es ist sieben uhr morgens und es ist
eiskalt die achtjährige ist krank sie
friert und sie ist hungrig
und doch beginnt sie auch an diesem
morgen ihre tägliche routine bis zum
abend wird sie so auf der straße sitzen
[Musik]
immer weniger erwachsene sind bereit ein
paar afghani zu geben um ihre schuhe
putzen zu lassen
fatima hat nie eine schule besucht das
einzige was sie gelernt hat ist auf der
straße zu überleben
ich putze den staub damit weg
mit dem pool ihre ich damit es glänzt
und damit färbe ich die schuhe
[Musik]
damit auch
ist es das was der westen nach 20 jahren
zurück lässt schon vor der
machtergreifung der taliban zählte
afghanistan zu den ärmsten ländern der
welt jetzt droht drei millionen kindern
unterernährung eine million kinder
drohen daran zu sterben
ich treffe mich in kabul mit dem
kinderarzt dr er hat uns in sein haus
eingeladen
im september hatte er uns durch das
krankenhaus geführt in dem er arbeitet
nach unserem bericht im zdf über die
katastrophale lage hat die deutsche
hilfsorganisation arche mit hilfe
angeboten vor allem lebenswichtige
medikamente zu liefern nun hat der
nachricht erhalten die medikamente aus
deutschland sind eingetroffen
am hamid karzai flughafen haben die
taliban die kontrolle übernommen
patroullieren dort mit ehemaligen us
fahrzeugen inzwischen ist der
flugverkehr wieder angelaufen aus abu
dhabi ist heute eine maschine angekommen
darin auch die lieferung aus deutschland
medikamente im wert von 25.000 euro
der zollchef kümmert sich persönlich an
diesem morgen um die abwicklung die
taliban machen klar wie wichtig ihnen
die spende aus deutschland ist
was immer wir bekommen wir werden dafür
sorgen dass die mgs und auf die
hilfslieferungen sicher sind so gott
will das islamische emirat wird dafür
sorgen dass es zu den richtigen leuten
geht ich danke ihnen allen für diese
hilfe
tatsächlich geht alles schnell und
unbürokratisch
und wenig später ist dr cool mit den
medikamenten unterwegs zum krankenhaus
doch hier nimmt die geschichte eine
überraschende wendung
der direktor der klinik ist gekommen
will sehen was in den kisten ist er will
selbst für die verteilung der
medikamente sorgen dass habe das
gesundheitsministerium so entschieden
drh de gaulle ist verzweifelt
schließlich kontaktierte das
gesundheitsministerium
[Musik]
ich werde versuchen zu verhindern dass
diese medikamente dem direktor des
krankenhauses ausgehändigt werden
wohin will ich bin sicher es geht um
korruption
sie wollen die medikamente austausche
ich hoffe jetzt dass der direktor mich
unterstützen wird wurde und uns nicht
daran hindern die medikamente an die
patienten zu geben
eine taliban delegation aus dem
gesundheitsministerium kommt schließlich
zum krankenhaus die taliban wollen
wissen was mit der deutschen
hilfsorganisation arche mit vereinbart
wurde dr google macht klar er ist für
die deutschen der ansprechpartner er
muss die verteilung organisieren und
darüber rechtfertigung ablegen gemeinsam
gehen wir ins zimmer des direktors hier
werden wir zeugen einer debatte um die
frage wer ist zuständig
das ist die regel der ngo eine person
muss zuständig sein denn diese leute
haben angst sie wollen dass alles
korrekt läuft denn vorher wurde
gestohlen
der direktor wehrt sich gegen die
vorwürfe
er behauptet in seinem krankenhaus laufe
alles korrekt
wenn es korruption gab dann im lager des
ehemaligen ministeriums
im krankenhaus der doktor kennt mich er
war mein schüler hier ist das wichtigste
was wir kriegen geben wir direkt in
kranken patienten
[Musik]
mehr als 1000 kinder werden im indira
gandhi kinderkrankenhaus behandelt viele
müssen sterben weil es nicht einmal
genug antibiotika gibt dr gold mit
zwillinge eines der kinder hat einen
herzfehler
[Musik]
dieses kind hat keine chance in
afghanistan zu überleben aber ihm wird
es besser gehen in ein zwei tagen
mit hilfe der taliban setzt sich der
kinderarzt gegen den direktor des
krankenhauses durch für ihn trotz aller
probleme ein hoffnungsschimmer dass die
korruption weniger wird auf der
intensivstation
verteilt der kinderarzt die so dringend
benötigten medikamente damit so hofft er
können einige kinder gerettet werden die
dreijährige fatima hat schwere
mangelerscheinungen immer mehr kinder
sterben an folgen von hunger doktor gold
zeigt die spezialnahrung die sie
erhalten
das ist wohl das geben sie den kindern
aber sie haben nicht mehr genug davon
es ist nicht genug für alle aber wir
versuchen es patienten besonders
kritischen zustand zu geben also nicht
jeder
so müssen sie darüber entscheiden wer es
bekommt und wer nicht
wer entscheiden welchen patienten wäre
es geben oder nicht wir haben einfach
nicht genug wir geben erst den patienten
die es am dringendsten brauchen
[Musik]
es ist ein teufelskreis
die internationalen geber wollen das
neue regime nicht finanziell
unterstützen
doch ohne hilfszahlungen droht dem land
der kollaps
fatima hat an diesem tag glück gehabt
sie hat genug verdient um auf dem
heimweg brot für die familie zu kaufen
die ganze tüte kostet umgerechnet einen
euro
es ist eines der wenigen lebensmittel
die sich nicht extrem verteuert haben
immer mehr familien ernähren sich nur
noch davon
wir begleiten die achtjährige nach hause
oft hängt es von ihr ab ob ihre
geschwister hunger leiden
hat sich die situation mit den taliban
verändert wird eher schlimmer
die situation hat sich verändert es gibt
kaum arbeit wir schulden seit monaten
die miete und der besitzer will bezahlt
werden wir haben es geschafft die miete
um 500 afghani zu reduzieren wir zahlen
jetzt 2500 im monat so ist das thema und
ihr vater verdienen das geld sie ist
eine junge frau und es ist nicht richtig
sie arbeiten zu lassen aber wir haben
keine wahl
wir haben fatima versprochen mit ihr auf
den basar zu gehen und etwas für sie und
ihre geschwister einzukaufen sie alle
möchten warme decken weil sie nachts
frieren
was wünscht du dir außer einer warmen
decke
schuhe und nichts zu spielen sie möchte
aber sie weiß nicht was
es hat sie nie mit etwas gespielt
hast du schon einmal später gehabt nein
es hat sich in der straße schnell
herumgesprochen dass wir zu gast bei
fatimas familie sind immer mehr nachbarn
tauchen auf auch in der hoffnung dass
wir sie unterstützen
wir dürfen afghanistans kinder nicht
vergessen mahnt unicef das
kinderhilfswerk der vereinten nationen
auch
in der sache ohne schule hoffen sie dass
die westliche welt afghanistan nicht
vergisst und sich die leeren
klassenräume wieder füllen
wenn die internationale gemeinschaft
entscheidet und zu helfen dann haben wir
eine chance für eine bessere zukunft
sonst werden die mädchen hier im leben
nichts erreichen deshalb bitte ich sie
und die internationale gemeinschaft
diesen armen leuten zu helfen
international isoliert könnte das land
in wenigen wochen einen kollaps erleben
das schicksal von millionen afghanen
liegt auch in den händen der
internationalen gemeinschaft für den
westen ein dilemma den menschen
beizustehen ohne das regime der taliban
zu stärken
[Musik]